o hoodie pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo e o estrago jequié bom hoje não é
um vídeo normal os faça um vídeo
especial porque porque com você e eu não
vou responder o que o meu nome
ontem eu recebi um convite do youtube
estúdios e porque não sabe o que é o
youtube tudo isso basicamente um estúdio
onde se ensina e editar vídeos que
basicamente estou agora com o novo
projeto que é o youtube é de mim é é que
minha do egito e não em tuba que é de
mil cd player e editar vídeos e fazer
conclusões e fazer aquelas coisas todas
que eu já faço aqui e também tem a parte
mais divertida que é fazer cessar o frio
a água muito louco é muito louco porque
eu estou a falar disso porque oito
estúdios convidou para passar um dia com
erros e eu próprio fui experimentar o
que estavam a propor que é basicamente
evitar fazer coisas manhã e à tarde ir
surfar na praia e obviamente aceitar e
nem porque o tipo nunca surfar e eu
tenho medo da água tanto esta foi a
oportunidade perfeita para eu
experimentar lembrando que vocês também
podem por vencer aqui é muito bacana e
por isso nem estou na descrição e foi
uma alegria foi uma festa por isso
estiveram emprestados por isso implica
também e vai muito no dia 5 que o filme
tudo ea e o filme no meu site magnífico
e três pessoas por posse de haxixe love
fiquem bem até a próxima época pessoal
sei que o estudo é que um do psol
aprender editar vídeos fogo à equipa
acrescenta que eu falei vou entrar ali
está o pessoal todo
um fica super bull pbr
háháhá
hoje a data em que isso não quer
aprender a fazer e que ele sabia quantos
vídeos espanhol em cinco centímetros por
dia muito bom o youtube
o youtube é mãe de flexa no rio e quero
aprender a fazer isso para então vocês
vocês duas
mas pode vir comigo não é assim tão
justo
é um jogo muito a fazer aqui um jogo eu
já sabia e vídeos já aprendi isso não
interessa
o gol
oi sua busca por que mongol pela aí
encontrei a bonita eu vejo é o primeiro
obstáculo foi logo fato isto não serve
nem por que será né
toma cinco épocas nada aqui dentro da
área
empatar
olha bem uma ondinha primeira fase
encara os braços segunda faz subir o pt
o joelho
o pássaro outro pé preto isso mesmo
então olha o chopinho
ela vai vai ai ai ai gente que gosta